[Music]
tonight on
the week in 60 minutes we're going to
look at brexit vaccines
and the u.s election and then we're
going to take your questions both oral
questions
and written we thank again the nat west
group for their support for this program
they backed the first program
we put out last week and they've kept
the faith with us this week
that west is the biggest supporter of
businesses across the uk
and is working hard during the pandemic
to help businesses
and personal customers get through this
difficult period
now to launch the spectator tv
uh we're only one week old and we're
giving viewers the opportunity to try
12 weeks of the magazine in print and
online
for just 12 pounds i mean we're almost
giving it away and you
receive a 20 pound amazon gift
voucher absolutely free so i mean
12 pounds for 20 pounds even i can do
the arithmetic there
go to spectator dot co dot uk tv offer
and become a spectator subscriber today
uh
with amazon there amazon as you know
they struggle to make any money in
britain and they pay
such massive taxes i think last year
they paid at least 50 quid
so it's only right we give them a little
boost as well
now first to brexit brexit is back
back with a vengeance this week and
there's been some breaking news just in
uh there's a dramatic week with brexit
and boris
gov johnson's government admitting that
it plans to break
international law to rewrite parts of
the withdrawal agreement this afternoon
surprise surprise brussels hit back
the eu has threatened the uk with legal
action if it does
not ditch a bill to override key parts
of the brexit divorce deal by the end of
the month
so how will the government respond are
the brexit trade talks about to break
down
well before the prime minister's own
deadline they were taking place
this week not much of a breakthrough
seems to have happened we have the
spectators
frieza nelson james forsyth and katy
balls here to answer these questions and
more
james let me come to you first talks to
a place this week
not a lot seems to have happened the
government
admits that it's doing something illegal
there's uproar
the eu's now going to take us to court
you can really say that we were heading
seamlessly to
a free trade deal could you yeah i think
the drama is
ramping up and i don't see either side
backing down the government aren't going
to drop this
internal market bill that has so enraged
the eu
and the eu isn't going to stop insisting
on
the full enforcement of the withdrawal
agreement and the northern ireland
protocol
the only way out of its deadlock i can
see is a breakthrough in either the
joint committee
or the trade talks now the uk side are
insistent that this is not a strategy
to crash the talks they say that they're
trying to create a moment of reality
here
and they argue that this week's talks
have actually been
uh low bar admittedly more constructive
than the last few rounds they think that
developments this week have made both
sides look over the precipice of what
would happen if there isn't a deal
and they hope that might inject the
urgency into the talks
that might create the movement needed
for a deal but i think this is a very
very
high risk high-stakes game they are
playing
because you not only see the eu
threatening to take the uk to court
but you see uh joe biden making clear
but
there's no trade deal on his watch if
this happens and nancy pelosi has been
making that clear as far as she's having
the house and so i think this is they
are playing a very high stakes game
and they are trying to ramp the pressure
up in the belief that
some that that will create the space for
concessions
i think the danger is but the eu
side are determined to kind of respond
in kind
and if you think back to last october
there was an opportunity when you know
boris johnson leo braga went to that
hotel in cheshire
and they walked around the place they
could come up with a deal the problem
now
in that situation you only need to
square the irish to get a deal
this time around you need to square 27
countries and that is a far more
difficult job
katie what are the tory backbenchers
saying i mean when you have a staunch
brexiteer
like michael howard former conservative
leader leader of the opposition
uh no one believes in brexit more than
him
and he says the government was wrong to
go down this
illegal route what's the mood on the
tory back benches about this uh
frankly pretty unprecedented situation
the government's got itself into
well i think in truth is actually quite
a mixed reaction
and we saw in the lords uh you mentioned
michael howard also norman lamont
it's not a great look when i suppose the
most senior tory brexiteers in the house
of zords
are saying they can't support the
government on this i think if you look
in the house of commons
there's a little bit more sympathy or
perhaps necessity to stay on board with
number 10 for various reasons
so you're not seeing a big backlash we
have had a handful of mps come forward
some brexiteers
some mps that you might call the usual
suspects ones that are unhappy with
propagation back when number 10 did that
and speak out and voice their concerns
tom tugan heart talking about the
importance of the rule of law
but i don't think we've seen that vocal
uh rebellion which suggests that you'd
have problems passing in this in the
commons
but behind the scenes there is a lot of
disquiet and i think this is because
what is clearly you know we can debate
uh when international law has been
broken previously
and there's lots of people who want to
do that but what is completely
unprecedented is having a cabinet
minister
stand at the dispatch box and say we're
breaking international law
um and not even try and you know say
well actually you can argue listen look
here
and i think that there are lots of tory
mps who want to be supportive to the
government on this they clearly see
brexit as
the flagship policy of this government
but they feel as they've been given
nothing that they can even point to you
know not even a fig leaf here
and i think that's led to uh quite a lot
of annoyance even if it's not going
public
and also just a sense that there was no
build up there was no uh you know ahead
of this announcement
and it wasn't a slip by brandon lewis as
far as we know you know this this is the
script
there is nothing to let well that's the
point i wanted to ask you about that
when i
saw the northern ireland secretary say
this at the dispatch box
in the commons the words uh
yeah we are breaking the law but it's in
a limited and specific
way i wonder if he just blundered but am
i right in thinking
these words were scripted for the forum
he had them
written in front of him yes i mean i
i i think a lot of people as you did
when we saw that we thought
that clearly can't be what he's supposed
to say he's fumbled his lines
actually i think that was the script and
i think that was for a few reasons
one being that there is a sense in
number 10 that if you look at the bill
that was later published
there's not that much to quibble about
it was quite obvious what they were
doing
um but also i think there was a sense
that i mean i had one figure in
government even say
we're not getting any credit for being
honest um
thinking perhaps they want
credit for being honest criminals is
that the government like
that i would say that it's a niche
position but it is one i have heard
uh in the past few days it did raise
eyebrows so
brandon lewis meant to say what he did
and i think that is again another factor
here because
tory mps are getting quite frustrated
thinking you're not giving us much to
work with
i think that people who are supportive
generally still have faith that
boris johnson and his team know what
they're doing with brexit but i think
what has happened this weekend as you
were talking about earlier the backlash
internationally
and what we're seeing currently in the
lords show that i think that you can
argue this this has backfired
james you wrote uh this week that the
prime minister feels the eu
has us the united kingdom over a barrel
on northern ireland can you just remind
me it wasn't
the same prime minister that actually
jumped into that barrel
yeah i think this this is the issue this
is the tension here which is
it's not the uk isn't just proposing to
break international law it is proposing
to
uh not abide by obligations that come
from a treaty that this prime minister
signed and that this
parliament passed various people say oh
no parliament combined its successor
well the parliament that has bound
itself is actually this current sitting
parliament that
voted through the withdrawal agreement
and i think that is the tension
i think what the uk side is trying to do
is trying to say to the eu
look there are going to be consequences
in the event of no deal
and we'll take action to preserve the
integrity of the uk in those
circumstances
i think the danger though is that this
is a kind of high risk strategy because
you talk to those people who are
veterans of no deal planning
and they say one of the most
unpredictable elements of it is how the
eu behaves you know
if the french decide to inspect every
laureate calais
there are going to be significant delays
if they decide
to operate a fairly pragmatic uh let's
wave things through and only check
things based on intelligence
then things might be much more smooth
and but if the talks break down
in total acrimony it's not it's hard to
imagine that the eu will be particularly
inclined
to take a pragmatic view i think i
suspect they will want to prove a point
and i think this is this is what the
danger of the approach is now
i would inject one note of caution here
which is in some ways before there was
going to be a deal
there has to be a massive row of
brussels now i i think that boris
johnson is
genuinely convinced of the need for this
approach you know he was
integral to the devising of this
strategy it comes out of an away day
that he held with his top political team
uh about 10 days ago but
i i think the point now is if there is
some movement now
on on the various issues we could
suddenly see you know i think that boris
johnson still does want a deal
but he very much wants to deal kind of
with the eu having moved rather than him
frasier let's sum it up for us please
can you
can you see your way forward here uh i
mean are we all just reacting too
quickly to the news is this all just the
kind of brinkmanship
that you would expect at this stage of
negotiations is there still a
what are the chances of doing a deal or
are we heading uh for no deal
i am still optimistic about a deal i
think it was always inevitable that
there was going to be brinkmanship we
were going to get this kind of theater
coming in one form or another
it's too kind to say the government
intended to do this there's clearly been
a massive mistake here and letting
brandon lewis say what he said a massive
gift
to the eu who's exploiting it very
cleverly
um but ultimately you know for all of
the missteps it is within the interest
of both britain and the eu to do a deal
so last time around we saw how the
choreography went it looked to all the
world
as if there was going to be no deal we
are preparing for it but at the last
moment
a deal came through i've always expected
we'd have the same pattern
this time and that a deal would come
only at the last minute so i suspect
we're going to see a few more of these
dramas here and before the year is out i
said that was the last word but i do
want to just go back to james because
something has just crossed my mind a
number
people have been asking it because james
points out there was no need for brandon
lewis to say what he said he could
simply have invoked
article 16 of the northern ireland
protocol
which has safeguards and uh ways if
there are disagreements for the british
government
to pursue these things but james just
mark our card on this
if there is no deal does
on a free trade agreement does the
the withdrawal agreement which was which
has already been signed and in law
that still has legal status whether we
sign a deal or no deal is that correct
yeah exactly and that is why the
government needs to legislate for this
because
if there is no deal and no agreement in
the joint
or government feels it needs to
legislate this if there is no deal or no
agreement in the joint committee
you would be in a situation where every
good that goes from great britain to
northern ireland
would have to pay tariffs and that money
would be refunded in time if you could
prove that that good had stayed in
northern ireland
but it didn't slip over the border into
the republic but that would essentially
dislocate northern ireland from the uk
economy now
the when you put it to people in senior
people in government why didn't you use
article 16 and say oh the problem with
article 16
is that it would get adjudicated in the
european court of justice
and you wouldn't win the case i think
the the argument is though
is that the uk has massively stepped off
the moral high ground here
and i think that you could start saying
that the eu's refusal to for example
agree that supermarket british
supermarkets that export to northern
ireland
can have their goods uh inspected
at their depots rather than you know
when they arrive in northern ireland
you could say that that is not
negotiating good faith and because the
eu is not negotiating in good faith
we're going to do this i think if you
look at um michael howard and norman
lamont's comments
what is causing the unease is the uk
government
saying that it is going to be the first
mover in terms of breaking the breaking
the agreement rather than accusing the
eu of breaking the agreement
and i think you know as someone said to
me this week you know this is
what brandon lewis said is worse than a
crime it's a mistake
right that's a good point to leave it
but of course we'll be back on brexit
it's not going away
and it has come back with a bang now
this week as you all know the government
tightened its uh covert restrictions it
seems sometimes
the only way out of this whole problem
is uh
the hundred billion pound moonshot
testing project if
you believe in that and in unicorns too
or a vaccine
this week there was concerning news for
the uk's best hope in the vaccine race
the
oxford vaccine trials with astrazeneca
were suspended
after a trial patient fell ill however
the race to find a covert job
is more intense than ever there are
seven major contenders
in the final stages or at least what
maybe the final stages
across the globe and which one wins will
have consequences not just for covet
but for our lifestyles but for
geopolitics is too
let's go to fraser he's going to talk us
through this week's spectator cover
story
which is on this very subject fraser
thank you andrew well yes when we saw
chris whitney and boris johnson declare
last night that they're going to do
these more restrictions
there was also a phase in the
presentation where they were saying they
were optimistic
very optimistic about not just the
moonshot of doing
um several rapid kind of do you have
coverage or not tests
but the vaccine itself now until
a few days ago the british vaccine was
seen to be the one
um ahead the whole situation is depicted
rather wonderfully by our cover artist
morton morland
this week so it is something equivalent
to the space race here with each country
coming up with its own vaccine now of
course they're all doing it for the
greater good of mankind but when you
um look at the sort of names which
they're given it's something out of a
bond film
you've got we talk about the oxford
vaccine well it's half oxford half
astrazeneca
and here we can see um
boris johnson's matt hancock clinging on
to it there's 14 billion pounds of
government money
here and they are um
they've been trying to minimize how much
of a problem it was
that and this week when one of the
people who was on the trial
feels seriously ill they've had to pause
that trial now
to while they investigate now matt
hancock says this is perfectly normal
for vaccines it happens all the time he
said it was actually the second time
this has happened um but nonetheless
none of the other
eight contenders have had to pause the
trials
so this has put some question as to
whether the british vaccine which had
been given to more people
than any other really was in front but
also this week we had some interesting
news from the russian
vaccine which is gloriously called
sputnik
now you um you might we might laugh at
this but
the lancets and did a review a few days
ago
saying it's actually been quite given
very encouraging phase two
trials um and mr putin i'm told has
taken it
and his daughter has taken it as well
well he's given it
putin has declared it safe personally
he's actually gone so far as to approve
it which is
perhaps um going a bit today but he said
his daughter is feeling very well that's
um what he told us a few days ago um so
there we are but the russian and the
british vaccine are the same
sorts of formula you you will give um so
they're they're
very similar both now of course there's
questions asked as to how real
the phase ii russian m trials were one
of the experts there is said it looks
photoshopped
to him but we'll see we can expect this
sort of
um comings and goings but not to be
outdone we've got donald trump on
operation
warp speed this is seriously the name
which he's given to the attempts to get
something like 300 000 vaccines
ready 53 million vaccine story ready by
january
now he rather unnerved people um a few
days ago by saying
that he's confident the american vaccine
will be ready by a certain date
of course we all know what deity meant
he meant election date
and now that had led all eight vaccine
manufacturers to put out a statement
assuring the world that they would not
be rushing this
there would not be any undue haste in
finding a vaccine
but this does matter of course because
there's two major theories about
coverage right now um the swedish
approach
is that you the unbiased might never
emerge so you've got
to learn to live with the virus that you
will keep managing it as long as a virus
doesn't overwhelm the health facilities
then that's okay now the swedish
approach after
or went wrong initially it ended up
almost as bad as britain in terms of
deaths per capita but as of a few hours
ago sweden is now back
on the list to which brits can travel
because its levels are
are so um far down that about half the
level of belgium
but belgium is still the model which the
british government is following
because it saw a rise in cases and the
british government thinks that belgium
acted
quickly and effectively to reverse that
rise in cases
so strangely we are now on the belgian
so this is why we're getting the cycle
of the rule of six as boris johnson
calls it this rather game of thrones
style name is given to his
rule that nobody more than six people
are allowed to to gather together
we can expect more i understand
ministers were discussing a curfew
we're discussing exemplary and police
raids where they go and raise some bunch
of unsuspecting students
because number 10 thinks that britain as
a country
needs to be a lot less confident a
little bit more
concerned even a bit more fearful and
that that behavior
might slow the stem of the virus when
the swedes had
and test surging they thought well as
long as hospital numbers don't go up it
doesn't matter
so two very different approaches
as i understand that belgium has the
worst record in terms of fatalities uh
per million
uh even worse than the united kingdom
exactly why are we following belgium
well
we had chris whitey the chief medical
officer and describe it as a choice
between three countries approach
spain france and belgium he shows some
graphs saying that spain has allowed
their
second wave infections if it really is
that to surge out of control
that france did the same thing but
belgium moved quickly
and whitty's graph shows the second wave
of belgian infections stopping halfway
through
and then falling away because they
brought in restrictions
they did they brought in curfews and
antwerp you weren't allowed to go out
after
half past 11 there was even a
supermarket sweep style rule where
you're only allowed to spend 30 minutes
in the supermarket so um rules in
belgium which
went way beyond what we had even in
lockdown but if that's the model if we
are
pursuing a strategy which wants to have
as few coveted infections as possible
then we can expect a lot more of
restrictions this week's cut
curbs could be the beginning of a lot
more to come the the government
and its chief medical officer is
undoubtedly right that there's been a
resurgence in cases in france and spain
uh that's been happening for several
weeks now
but as of yet there's been no dramatic
change in the number of fatalities in
these countries they've risen
but they've risen from a very small base
the the relationship
in france and spain between cases and
fatalities
is nothing like what it was at the
height of the crisis in
april may and june that's right that
ratio between the number of deaths and a
number of cases is through the floor
all over europe right now now what chris
whittie would say
is that don't be fooled there is a lag
you might think for
cases arising now and there's not deaths
but those deaths will come because the
young transfer it to the old
then there's a lag of hospital numbers
then there's a lag of death so if the
quizzy hypothesis
is correct then we will start to see a
rise in french deaths and a rise
in spanish deaths before too long he
says there's about a three-week lag
between the actions he's taking now
and what he expects to see in britain so
in a way he's gambling he's gambling
that the swedes are wrong to think but
you can tolerate a rise in infections as
long as there's no hospital
levels he wants to preemptively move now
but he hasn't convincingly explained why
he's sure but the belgian approach is so
much better
than the swedish approach okay fraser
thank you for that
let's look more at this vaccine issue
now i'm delighted
to say we're joined by dr elizabeth
grappelli
a virologist and lecturer in global
health at st george's university of
london
she's an expert on the development of
novel and affordable
vaccines uh dr grappelli welcome to the
week in
60 minutes can i just clarify because we
all got a bit nervous when we saw this
setback
uh of the oxford vaccine as we're
calling it this week
but am i right in thinking that actually
what has happened is entirely normal
in the development of these vaccines
absolutely
it is a very frequent that clinical
trials
especially as they go into the last
phase which is called phase three
which also involves lots of thousands of
volunteers
but also involves different countries
it's very very often that it
happens that the trials needs to be
posed because trials
are skewed very much towards the side of
caution
in the sense that as soon as something
uh and
happens everything just pauses so that
an investigation can occur
and sometimes uh the most important
question is actually
to investigate if what's being detected
as an adverse reaction is actually due
to the vaccination and as we've heard
for the oxford astrazeneca
um vaccination vaccine there has been
already a pose
only a couple of months ago that
actually was not linked to
the vaccine and therefore the trial
could it could
go ahead but this is also why normally
we do take
years decades to develop to develop a
vaccine and so
this is expected and i would like to put
into the context at the moment
there have been two poses in the vaccine
trial for oxford
out of at least 18 000 people who have
received
the vaccine or the placebo and this
astonishing these are human beings that
actually go about
their own lives and it's found that
actually out of 18
000 people someone will fall ill also
independently of the vaccine so we need
to take this
into consideration as well and i
understand you are one of the
18 000 doctor you've had you've been a
volunteer for the vaccine
tell us what the process is like yes
absolutely um
it's uh for me it was absolutely a
no-brainer in terms of uh
signing up as a volunteer of course i
have
the benefits of the uh of the knowledge
of virology and also knowing my
colleagues
but it's also virology in action um
i was um assigned i signed up for the
trial uh as soon as he opened
in the uk outside of oxford i am based
in london
and this was early in uh in may
and then there's been a follow-up visit
so that uh so my i could uh
get a blood test to see how my body was
reacting
uh at that moment i didn't know if i had
been given at the
oxford vaccine or all the placebo and
that's basically
i have i can obviously share that i am
perfectly fine
and although obviously i am being
monitored because
this is part of the trial so earlier
this week i did receive
an email from the trial organizer and
notifying me
about the adverse um case that
the the illness that had been diagnosed
and the investigation that was pending
and to be honest again as a virologist i
was kind of expecting it so
for me there hasn't been any
apprehension or any disappointment
just take it in a stride and wait for
the investigators
independently to assess what it is and
keep feeling in the questionnaires about
my potential exposures and how i feel
because i understand that what hangs
over all these
every time we try to develop a vaccine
for something is a case that goes back
to america the carter case in the 1950s
when
when i think they were trying to develop
something for polio and they ended up
with the injections actually
injected a lot of young people with the
polio
itself and that was such a horrendous
outcome that ever since
we've had to be very cautious in going
down this road is that correct
absolutely i mean it has to be said that
now we do have a different
platforms and different technologies
that actually
do not rely on what we call a growing
virus or a live virus and that actually
has to be
killed before it can be given to
volunteers
and this is also why uh these vaccines
like uh
the the uh oxford vaccine can be
uh fast strapped without the shortcuts
but they can be fast-tracked
because they are very different they are
very novel generation of vaccines that
already
because of the neurological principles
that
are at the fundamentals of their designs
are already safer
having said that they could be
fast-tracked but the experiment
or the experimentations actually still
needs to be done
according to the new rules or the rules
you know the current rules
which are very much safety first and
this is also phase one and phase two
and then uh efficacy and i'll just would
like to
comment about uh you know the the
russian vaccine the sputnik five
which uh has been just pointed out um
that is a is a
technology very similar to the to the
one uh
with oxford and in that case however um
it has only been given to less than a
hundred
uh people when they are maxing already
eighteen thousand
so this is the massive difference when
we talk about a front runner
when we talk about different vaccines
being in developed uh
actually you know there are quite a lot
of differences in the numbers
that actually can give us a little bit
of an insight
if a setback is important or not two out
of 18 000
it's pretty good stance at the moment
for me does it worry you
that we seem to have a there's almost
like a sort of geopolitical
vaccine nationalism going on here and
and the giveaway from the spectators
cover story this week of course it
it is that russia has called it sputnik
5. mr trump is calling
his the the operation warp speed
uh i mean is this a good thing in that
they're all competing
like mad and to try and be the first or
is it actually something that's a bit
scary
uh well in science actually a little bit
of competition
even if it comes from national pride and
you know a little bit of stereotypical
cold war
scenarios it's actually quite good
because uh you know the more
uh you know the more brains we have are
tackling a problem
uh the better we are at coming up with a
solution and a solution that might not
be just
one but because we might need actually
more than one
so a little bit of competition that
actually fuel and bring the best
out of us absolutely is fantastic
however this has to stop the moment
something
a vaccine has been deemed safe and
effective
because this is the moment when we need
to absolutely make sure
that a vaccine is made available for the
entire world
this is a pandemic fine let's have a
race if we want
when it comes to developing a little bit
of national pride but let's not forget
that this is a nasty virus it causes
death
and and and the vaccine the solution uh
needs to be available for every human
being
across the globe indeed should we be
worried though supposing russia
uh it gets on well with its vaccine
given the number of people has been
tested they may add more to it and so on
more trials
but would we in britain and europe and
the
united states would we not be a bit
nervous about this because it
might it would not have seemed to
have mounted the hurdles that we would
expect for our own vaccines
absolutely the most important thing is
that there are
european regulators and also uh uk
regulators that they want to and need to
assess the data before anything is
approved
at the moment there is also a little bit
of debate about
obviously we said you know about brexit
about exactly what's going to be
the path that the uk will use to
actually approve a vaccine that has not
been developed
in the uk itself but one thing is clear
whatever applies
in terms of criteria for safety and
efficacy to the oxford vaccine will
apply to any other vaccine that comes
out
anywhere in the world and therefore we
will want to see the data
solid transparency before it is actually
allowed
for use for license for use in the uk so
if our authorities and our regulators
and medical experts like you if they say
that this chinese vaccine all this
russian vaccine
it is safe to use you'll be saying that
on the basis
that it's passed all the tests uh that
we would have expected the
oxford vaccine to pass to absolutely
before
before we can allow it in in this
country
we will want to see the data but also
there will be
uh so data not as as published but also
the nitty-gritty
of the data and be absolutely convinced
uh by the data there cannot be any any
doubt
that maybe something has been
photoshopped absolutely that's the case
and so
it's great to see that there is a
competition
speed but there cannot be shortcuts and
the the transparency of the data will
have to be there
for actually make sure that or get
convinced that uh whatever the russian
or the chinese vaccines
are actually appropriate for our country
dr group just one final uh question
um this this
as i understand it covert is a variant
of the common code
and we don't have a vaccine for the
common cold
even though it's been around forever
that would strike me that we're trying
to do it all at huge speed as well as
you've been telling us
that would strike me is that it's a i
mean it's a
hell of a challenge yes it is vaccines
are viruses
are and so many other pathogens um i i
need to point out
that the common cold so what we call the
common cold
is actually caused by a variety of
viruses some are coronaviruses some are
called picornoviruses
but you're absolutely right we do not
have a vaccine
for you know the common cold either
caused by the picorino viruses or
caused by the coronaviruses and so um
for the corona viruses especially is
that they are
also quite new they've been identified
only a few decades ago
but the most important thing is that so
far the common cold
has been for the majority of us all over
the world
not a particularly nasty infection
and it's only natural when it's man flu
of course it's very serious as you know
absolutely absolutely
absolutely and i hope for you know we
should devote more resources actually to
cure
that ameliorate that for the benefit of
women as well
absolutely dr grapelli thank you very
much for uh marking our garden that has
been
fascinating to listen to you and good
luck with all the wonderful work you're
doing
thank you very much now let's move and
go across the pond to the u.s
elections you're watching the week in 60
minutes it's coming to you from
spectator tv
we thank our sponsor the natwest group
for supporting
our second broadcast and for the support
they're giving businesses
up and down the country in these
difficult covered
times we're two months away from the u.s
election a little less than that it's
early this year on november the 3rd the
campaign started late because labor day
came late
uh this year as well the race for the
270
electoral college votes is well underway
now the national polls
have mr biden comfortably ahead
but in some of the key battleground
states
uh that will determine the election
things are beginning to look
a little tighter wouldn't overdo that
but they're looking a little tighter
let's go to the
editor of the spectators us edition
freddie gray
for an update freddie what can you tell
us well andrew i think the
the major theme at the moment in the
american election is uncertainty
and that's not just because the polls
are dubious it's because
uh the actual process is in doubt at the
moment we we're going to have a huge
increase in the number of mail-in
ballots we think um
postal votes as we call in in britain uh
could be up to half the number of votes
and already there are huge political
fights erupting
over whether they're legitimate um
who counts what in each state and so on
and so you could get a situation i think
we're probably going to have a situation
where we're not going to have a usual
election night
and in the weeks that follow we're going
to have terrible contesting of results
that will go on and on and on and things
will get very very ugly
i saw freddie some u.s commentators
saying
that on election night as the results
come in and they're being counted these
are the people
who've gone to vote donald trump will
likely emerge the winner
and then when the mail-in votes from the
postal votes are counted in and that
could all be done perhaps
by the sunday most of it joe biden could
be the winner
well that's the great fear at the moment
is if trump clearly wins on election
night
without the full counts in a lot of
states he declares victory
and then five days later it's cancelled
by the actual results
but there are also great fears that if
if trump wins by a margin a lot of
democrats are going to say
the postal votes weren't counted
properly and it will be contested so
i think fascinating as it is to look at
the various states and i hope we'll do
that in a moment
i think the real worry at the moment is
that whatever the result is
no one will be happy with it why did
they take so long
to count the postal votes i mean i think
in this country we sometimes count them
beforehand
or we count them on the day along with
all the actual votes
well there are a lot of people saying
this is all fear-mongering and that
actually the postal service
will work fine but there do seem to be
substantial delays in the post-op in the
american postal service at the moment
and the worry is the overload will be so
huge
that it will cause substantial delays
freddie take us through some of these
swing states i think you've got some
data on
places like florida which is key for mr
trump
i don't think he can win without north
carolina pennsylvania mr biden's
home state minnesota which is i
understand i think it shows
one of the states that mrs clinton won
and maybe one of the few states that
went democrat that could go mr trump's
way
well precisely if we if we get this
share screen going
that's the overall uh polling
uh average which i don't actually think
is is that useful because
it shows that's nationwide nationwide
yeah
uh and it still shows biden uh
substantially ahead a little tightening
uh in the last few months and then a
little pulling away in the most recent
polls
if we then move on to what is
effectively the betting market
on the next president's chances you see
around the time of the national
convention
you see a massive crossover which is
where the betting people decided that
trump was going to win
uh and then again as we got away from
those conventions people start to trust
biden's victory a bit more
and i think that's very telling i think
the betting market's a much more
reliable indicator
than the national polls
people place their money is uh a better
uh
indicator than what people tell posters
i absolutely do i think it i think it is
i think um a lot of people
uh don't you know we know there's a shy
trump factor
nobody knows quite how big it will be
the shy trump factor would be
people who don't tell pollsters they're
going to vote for trump and then do
but those people might just say to vote
to pollsters yes i think
trump's going to do it so i think the
betting market is more interesting but
even in the betting market you see biden
as the head so that's not necessarily
good news
seven points for trump uh but the so the
interesting thing comes down to these
various key battleground states and the
biggest one the big one for trump in
2016 was florida
so if we look at that uh we can see
that it it's getting tighter
again you see a little flick towards
biden recently one percentage point is
well within any
margin of error well so a pollster told
me last weekend that uh
you can probably account five points for
a
shy trump vote so that would suggest
that florida is looking pretty good for
trump at the moment
and then and then of course it moves on
to other states and we look to
somewhere like north carolina because as
in 2016 freddie
he has to win mr trump has to win
florida
but that's not enough uh it's not enough
i mean he can lose florida and still win
yes i think he can but i think it's it's
a very very difficult path
to do so uh and here's north carolina
you're showing us again
he has north carolina is going to be
very very tight and the big question
north carolina is a large
african-american vote
the african-american folk famously was
quite depressed
in 2016 they weren't that excited about
hillary clinton the early indications
are
that they were quite keen on joe but the
african-american voters were keen on joe
biden
will they come out for him in november
that would be very telling in north
carolina at the moment
again it's a total toss-up as you can
see from this
chart uh and so let's look to another
state which is pennsylvania which is a
very interesting one because trump won
that by a very very small margin
in 2016 and biden has this tremendous
home advantage she's a scranton
pennsylvania boy
he seems to have very solid polling
there but i've spoken to republicans who
think that they will still get
pennsylvania
and if they get pennsylvania and a
couple of other swing states they don't
necessarily need
florida ah that's how interesting it
works
yes i mean the one thing that would seem
to be clear is
that uh mr
biden wins the popular vote he i mean
he'll
like hillary clinton in 2016 he will get
more votes
nationwide than mr trump but he still
has uh has a it is still not
quite clear that that translates into
enough electoral
college votes to give him victory well
exactly
and i think what's very interesting is
that i mean given that the democrats
have never really accepted the 2016
result
what happens if the same thing happens
again what happens if trump
loses the popular vote which he almost
certainly will but wins the electoral
college
how berserked the democrats go do they
contest it
to death in one recent game play
scenario some senior democrats suggested
that they would
they would propose that california
succeeds from the union if
they win the popular vote but lose the
electoral college again
so i mean i i know this sounds
hyperbolic but i think we could be
talking about
serious constitutional questions serious
civil unrest if trump wins again in that
way
so it sounds like there's at least
regardless of who's ahead america
between
polling day and christmas
or close to christmas could be heading
for a serious constitutional crisis
i think i think that's how i think
that's not unless somebody wins by a
landslide
yes unless someone who ends up by a
landslide and then everyone will say
it's a fix anyway so
we're all waiting for the first debate
freddie on september the 29th it's in
cleveland
that's going to be great car crash
television i guarantee you
we better see if we can get it on to
spectacular tv then
at the moment would it still not be fair
to say
freddie that this is biden mr biden's
election
to lose uh i think
yes i think given uh that this book this
is
pretty much in most americans minds
there seems to be a referendum on trump
uh but biden's great problem is that
he's more successful
when he's invisible from the electorate
and it's impossible for him to be
invisible
from the electorate as we approach an
election but as voters are actually
confronted with the choice between two
candidates
they start to realize it's a biden
versus trump vote rather than the trump
versus i don't like trump vote
and if it becomes a biden versus trump
vote then a lot of voters might start to
realize
that they're not that keen on biden and
they're not that keen
on an obama era restoration which is
what
biden's proposing right freddie we'll
leave it there but we'll be right back
to that too it's the most fascinating
run-up i can remember to a u.s election
and of course we'll all be
watching that first debate on the 29th
not long to
uh to to go for that uh we've got about
15 minutes to go here on uh
the week in 60 minutes it's time now for
your questions we are going to take some
that been sent in but i can also see
some of you have your
digital hands waving let me try a
digital hand
we had a little trouble with these last
week but we got it in the end let me try
magnus burt
magnus i wanted to ask um
about essentially the covid treatments
which uh cyanogen i heard had developed
treatment which in the phase ii trial
has uh reduced the number of cases
uh not cases i mean the ultimate severe
disease
by about eighty percent in a phase two
trial
this is very good and reduces covert
death rates
there have been some treatments with
with some success
as this culvert crisis has gone on is
that right doctor
yes absolutely um the most important one
has been
dexamethasone which is a the very cheap
drug that is already used in the clinic
that has been shown to
very much reduce the mortality for the
most severe patients so the ones that
are already
in in hospital and that has been a
fantastic news that came out of actually
of the uk
run trial the the recovery trial there
has been
a separate data about another steroid
which is
another and heavily and easily used
which is hydrocortisone
a little bit more more mixed data when
it comes to
an antiviral which is called the
rendezvous and that accent not on the on
the hormones
of the human body but acts directly on
the virus but unfortunately
and the data is not as strong as the
other one so lots of progress
nothing yet specifically a major game
changer
but certainly a couple of drugs that are
going to be
helping the most severe cases uh
the ones that are being uh hospitalized
all right thank you for that
simon albury has written in with what is
ofcom's beef with you meaning the
program
so i mean it was just a joke don't take
it seriously i'm sure ofcom loves us
uh there let's go to lars fravert i
think is how you pronounce it
it's an interesting question james for
you what is there to stop the government
from breaching other parts of the
withdrawal agreement for example
the withdrawal agreement includes the
provisions protecting european citizens
rights i'm sure dr
griffely would be very interested in the
answer
to that question that's the problem
isn't it when you try to claim you're
just a little bit pregnant
yeah i think you can see the risk of
opening pandora's books which is that
there have been some
there are some amendments coming from
the european research group that kind of
really
hardline spartan tory brexiteers trying
to override
more of the world's law agreement not
not the sections on systems rights i
should stress but
more bits of the withdrawal agreement
now the government's defense is look
this is the proof but we're not ripping
up withdrawal agreement we're only
taking this very
targeted action but the problem is once
you say that you're entitled
to overrule one part of it it becomes
very hard to explain
why you won't overrule other bits of it
and so
i think the danger for the government is
that it ends up under far
from two sides of its own party in the
commons next week you know
one group of erg rebels saying we want
more of the withdrawal agreement
uh um disapplied uh and then uh we've
already seen an amendment put down from
bob neal
uh and the former deputy prime minister
damian green saying you know
you shouldn't be able to trigger these
northern ireland provisions without
another vote in parliament because of
the risk it would pose to the uk's
international reputation right exactly
now
here's another uh question that's uh
come in with an instant one
it's a written question and this again i
think is for you uh
doctor um if if britain does if the
oxford
astrazeneca vaccine becomes the
the front runner in this does that mean
that we in britain get it first
right well the really important thing
is that the uk government has already
bought
a substantial number of doses and has
ordered more
and the manufacturing process is
obviously at the
unlinked uh compared to the trial so
there is a
manufacturing going on already before we
know if the
vaccine is safe and effective and the
idea is very much that
as soon as uh there is the data and the
licensing
then we can start vaccinating so it
seems like the uk
is essentially in good place to get it
when it's ready
and there are however other doses that
are being manufactured for other
countries
and i think it's about uh it's
definitely important that
uk will have access to at least a few
vaccines
as soon as they are ready uh that
question was from ken pelton here's an
anonymous one i'll stick with you doctor
for the moment
could the government make any vaccine
like this
could it make it mandatory
that we have to have it right uh that
would be
it's i would say unlikely by the
realities that it is virtually
impossible in a in a modern western
democracy
and as much as a virologist i would
absolutely love to see
everybody who can have a vaccine also
take take it
the reality is that we're not just virus
hosts we are human beings with a
thinking brain
and therefore we need to be doing it
willingly
so if someone has concerns about a
vaccine and doesn't want to take it
i would invite a conversations to be had
discussions and yes from my point of
view convincing that vaccines are not
only safe but effective
and they are also in this particular
case extremely useful
to actually get us back to to real life
so not
mandatory uh but certainly any doubt
please let's let's talk about this
because it's very important and they do
work
right let's go to terry portman uh who's
got a question
uh with a little blue hand up terry over
to you
your question hi can you hear me
yes we can great um
so i'm curious about what we can do to
stop
um more virus
in the community um here in plymouth we
had a group come back from zanti
uh and 11 of them proved positive but
if you go and look at footage instagram
accounts etc you can see that there's
very little social distancing going on
over there clubs are open etc
so why is it taken three weeks for us to
react
to uh put this on a watch list and so
you can't travel there anymore when it
should have been obvious that there are
countries that have got
similar restrictions to us that are
taking it very seriously
and then other countries that aren't why
we why are we not
looking at um at these things
in a broad way rather than waiting for
data okay terry thank you for that can
you let me go to you on this
it it does seem that the government uh
i'm going to katie bowles here it can
seem the government has struggled
particularly among young people as the
universities are going back or
even in august when they got a chance to
have some holidays and party
social distancing pretty much fell by
the wayside among
that particular demographic didn't it
the government just couldn't enforce it
yes and i think that if you look at all
the restrictions the government are
currently talking about so you know the
rule of six
and when you speak to cabinet ministers
about this it goes back to young people
i think on xanthe and certain holiday
locations um
the government has actually been quite
worried about the fact that in certain
places
it's younger groups people relax more
when they go abroad
and that has been a factor um but i
think if we're looking ahead to what
this means for
uh the young going forward um we do have
a situation where looking ahead to
university
i think that part of the reason we're
getting these restrictions
is because they're really worried about
young people having all these late night
gatherings
but the question is i mean i had one
minister put it to me
probably young people as they drink a
lot and they have lots of sleepovers
adult sleepovers potentially
and they see that as a an issue in this
but it's hard to know exactly how to
play it because we're talking about
enforcement
how do we actually enforce this even
though the government is talking about
higher fines
i think there is an issue in putting
that in practice and they're probably
going to try and
uh make a big scene of letting go of a
few people of you know
finding people arresting people to try
and put others off because there's only
so much they can do
particle brian asks how seriously should
we take the comments by nancy pelosi
that there will be no
uk us trade deal of the government goes
ahead with his internal market plans i
mean freddie i think it's a
it's a bit more than that what nancy
pelosi has been saying is that if
if anything the british government does
undermines the good friday peace
agreement that will make it
much harder to get a free trade deal
through and i think whatever way we look
at the election it's pretty clear
that the democrats nancy pelosi being
the leader in the house there
uh they're going to hold on to the house
so it it it is a serious threat
it is a serious threat and it's also i
mean the irish question in america is
still very very interesting
think about the fact that joe biden is
an irish catholic american i mean how
does that
reflect on how he'll treat a brexit deal
in light of
in light of ireland i i mean my
impression is that
the boris johnson administration for a
while was very keen on
uh on the trump administration there was
lots of high hopes
about what could be done together on a
trade deal my impression is that that
those hopes have sort of dwindled a bit
in recent months
and that if you talk to people in
westminster they seem to be keen on the
idea of a biden administration
and that we could join a multilateral
trading deal
after biden becomes president so i i
think there is a there's also cooling
off between the johnson administration
and uh the trump administration a
question from sandeep
fazu uh again for our doctor he
wants to know what your thoughts are on
mass
testing which the government has been
digging up recently is it realistic to
be able
i mean one stage is talking about kind
of testing everybody
regularly is that when it's called a
moonshot it
sounds to me it might be as far away as
the moon doctor
yes i mean in principle uh it makes
sense
you know we want to know where the virus
is let's test everybody and because the
testing we have
at the moment they only tell us if
someone is so is infected at the time
that we take the test and so and that
can change 24 hours later so mass
testing
as frequent as as one once a day uh
yes logically but uh in the whole
hardcore reality of actually this planet
it's very um unrealistic and not just
particularly ambitious
and so and also it actually hits a point
which has been quite challenging for the
uk which is has been
not only testing in terms of increasing
capacity
but also making the test available and
also making the results available
to those who are actually needed so
there's quite a lot of groundwork that
needs to be done
again when it comes to delivering the
testing as we know about it
before we can start thinking about you
know massive
mass testing that it actually it looks
pretty much unrealistic and
unfortunately
it would require actually validation and
delivery of some
technological platforms like the rapid
tests which are not available at the
moment
and it's unlikely that will be available
at any time soon so
a little bit of realism possibly good
idea but let's stick
to what we know works and do that at the
best of our abilities
thank you thank you for that doctor
james let me come back to you in our
final
few minutes and inevitably come back to
uh brexit we
we've know what's happened this week we
we know the talks have continued
doesn't seem to they didn't break up but
there's not been much of a breakthrough
we've had this business with the british
government in legality we've had the eu
now saying it's going to take us to
court
look ahead for us we're not what in the
second week of september
what now happens within with brexit over
the next month or so
i think the big question with brexit now
is whether the principles
get involved by which i mean does macron
merkel the other eu national leaders get
involved because i don't think
the answer to these questions is going
to come out of the barnyard frost
discussions it's got to be
there's got to be the political will to
get a deal now i mean there's an
interesting question here
emmanuel macron is the most obvious
person i think
to have a conversation with boris
johnson that perhaps replicates some of
that leo variable conversation last time
around the french are the most hard line
but also boris johnson has no better
interpersonal relation with an eu leader
than emmanuel macron you know they enjoy
having dinner together
they get on they speak french together
indeed i think one of the problems here
is fish because there is no
good answer for emmanuel macron on fish
because the
the the nature of the uk becoming a
coastal state
so cuts back on what french fishermen
can catch
and i think one theory that is doing the
rounds at the moment is that macron
doesn't want to step
in because if he steps in and helps
broker a deal
he will have dipped his hands in the
fish cuts and french fishermen will say
our catch is falling dramatically
because of this deal that you broken mr
president
one as if macron sits back waits for no
deal
and then negotiate and then steps in you
know in the second half of 2021 say
to try and work on a deal french
fishermen will go from
having lost all of their quota in uk
waters to then getting some back from
the macron deal
so i mean there is a worry that the
macron isn't going to step in because of
his whole fishing question
the other big issue is angela merkel
right now the germans hold the
presidency of the european union
she is very reluctant to step in too
early
but as we saw again last time around
when things were looked like they were
heading for no
deal she is very worried about the
geopolitical implications
not the economic ones but the
geopolitical implications of a no deal
brexit
and the question is does she step in
towards the last
to try and broker a kind of compromise
and she did do that last time round
albeit in a limited way does she try and
do that again and i think the
reminder today is that you saw the e3
the uk france and germany
again taking the same position on iran
you had the
poisoning of russia's opposition leader
the other week there are a whole bunch
of geostrategic issues
where the uk's alignment with uh the eu
is very important does that prompt
angela merkel to step in and try and
find a way through this situation
james thank you for that we're going to
leave it there thanks to everybody
uh for joining us from the spectator
team and a special thanks to dr
grappelli for being with us tonight and
talking us through these complicated
matters
that is it for the week in 60 minutes it
was actually 63 minutes we overran just
a little bit
we'd like to know what you thought about
it how we could improve it we're always
out for improvement
so send your thoughts to spectator tv at
spectator dot co dot uk
thanks to all of our guests to you for
watching and once again to our
supportive sponsors at that west group
and the work they're doing to help
businesses during the covert crisis
you can watch again or recommend the
show to your friends it'll shortly be
ready for viewing
on the spectator website and on the
spectators youtube channel
we hope you'll join us again next
thursday at 6 p.m london time
for another week in 60 minutes until
then
goodbye
[Music]
you